[Music]
will you get out of here
thank you
[Music]
my name is Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spiderman and things are
going great oh yeah you're supposed to
be here all right whatever whatever
so are you like a cow or a Dalmatian I
am the spot
that's not funny
don't don't do that
miles's grades are pretty good A and AP
Physics that's my little man and a B in
Spanish what
okay miles
lying to you and I think you know it
[Music]
wanna get out of here oh win so wait a
minute there's an elite crew with all
the best spider people in it who's the
new guy this is unbelievable this is the
lobby
the whole thing with his idea what's the
guy I gotta do to join this spider team
you you can never be part of this don't
even get me started on Doctor Strange
and a little nerd back on Earth 1999.99
come on go easy on the kid he had a
terrible teacher Peter files you have a
baby
I'll take it from here
miles being Spider-Man is a sacrifice
you have a choice between saving one
person
and saving every world
foreign
I can't do that I can do both Spider-Man
always always what about Uncle Ben if
not for Uncle Ben most of us wouldn't be
here
you can't run forever dude I can't lose
one more friend
I had no idea what are you doing
telling me how my story is supposed to
go
I'm gonna do my own thing
stop Spiderman
[Music]
and then I looked at my uncle and ah let
me guess he died
[Music]
thank you